c'est vrai qu'il ya sept ce cadre les
quatre heures les taux de féminicide a
plus que je t'ai pas doublé mais bien
monté forcément on n'a pas encore tous
les chiffres officiels c'est très
difficile bourreau n'est jamais n'est
jamais loin finalement c'est le
confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il y en eût clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violence de nos empreintes pas à 3
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters voici les types de ce
lundi
christophe castaner promet la tolérance
zéro contre le racisme dans les forces
de l'ordre le ministre de l'intérieur
qui annonce l'abandon d'une méthodes
d'interpellation controversées dit de
l'étranglement une conférence de presse
alors que l'igpn a rendu son rapport
elle s'est vue confier 1460 dossier à
charge en 2019 un chiffre en hausse de
23,2 des nuls 7 % par rapport à 2018
un éventuel remaniement au sein du
gouvernement et un casting déjà bouclé
oui à en croire une note secrète de
gilles legendre le chef de file des
députés
l'arrêt m'adresser emmanuel macron est
révélée par l'hebdomadaire marianne
un document dans lequel edouard philippe
est mis sur la touche ce qui provoque la
colère de plusieurs députés marcheurs
d'autres réclament la tête de leur
président de groupe aux états unis les
obsèques de djordje floyd auront lieu
demain à houston cet homme froid
américain de 46 ans asphyxié lors d'une
interpellation de police le 25 mai
dernier le policier responsable de sa
mort doit comparaître aujourd'hui devant
la justice du minnesota où la mairie et
promet une réforme profonde de son
système policier
[Musique]
donald trump envisagerait de réduire le
nombre de militaires déployés en
allemagne informations du wall street
journal
le pays est le principal ancrage des
forces américaines de l'otan ce retrait
inquiète donc les allemands un risque
pour la sécurité est un coup dur pour
les relations germano américaines
[Musique]
christophe 4 s'avère a donc donné une
conférence de presse cet après midi le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est exprimé
sur les accusations de violences
policières et de racisme au sein des
forces de l'ordre
une sortie destinée à rassurer
l'exécutif emmanuel macron demande que
l'on améliore la déontologie des forces
de l'ordre parmi les mesures annoncées
d'interdiction de la méthode
d'interpellations vip de l'étranglement
et la suspension systématique en cas de
propos raciste avéré tolérance zéro pour
le racisme chez les policiers mise au
point nécessaire compte tenu de la
situation aux états unis avec la sphère
giorgio floride et coûteux au moment où
tous les anathèmes sont jetés j'aimerais
que chacun se rappelle que la france ce
n'est pas les états unis se rappelle que
policiers et gendarmes interviennent
pour chacun de nos appels qu'ils sont là
sans cesse présent face au terrorisme
face au crime face au traffic face aux
violences face au racisme aussi mais
parce qu'ils sont les gardiens de notre
république
j'ai pour nos forces de l'ordre une
exigence particulière et une
intransigeance plus forte encore alors
je le dis je le dis avec fermeté encore
une fois le racisme n'a pas sa place
dans notre société et encore moins dans
notre police républicaine
ces dernières semaines trop ont failli
dans leurs devoirs républicains des
propos racistes ont été proférées des
discriminations révélé c'est
inacceptable
alors nous avons agi en conséquence
systématiquement sans tarder à l'île
saint denis les policiers qui avait tenu
des propos odieux qu'on était suspendu
immédiatement
enfin vendredi j'ai décidé de signaler
au procureur de la république les propos
racistes et sexistes infecte tenu par un
groupe dans un groupe facebook au sein
duquel il y aurait des policiers et des
gendarmes
cela continuera je veux une tolérance
zéro contre le racisme dans notre
république
je veux que chacun sache que quand on
porte l'uniforme l'uniforme
de la loi on ne se situe jamais au
dessus d'elle et hasard du calendrier ou
pas c'est aujourd'hui que l'igpn la
police des polices a rendu son rapport
elle s'est vue confier 1460 dossier à
charge un chiffre en hausse de 23 7% par
rapport à 2018
une publication fait polémique sur les
violences policières souvent dénoncé par
les gilet jaune ou encore dans la sphère
adama traoré en après
après week-end de manifestations dans
tout le pays pour réclamer justice pour
tous les explications en images
[Musique]
il
alors la police française raciste ou pas
violente ou pas stéphane liégeois a posé
ces questions à quelques citoyens
bordelais écouter leurs réponses il ya
des policier raciste c'est là ils sont
gentils il faut punir les policiers
racistes comme n'importe quel raciste et
il faut pas faire d'amalgamé par ces
débris et qu'il faut vraiment bien leur
boulot qui est leur boulot elle est très
bien ce temps police impeccable depuis
qu'on est passé de gardiens de la paix a
forces de l'ordre je trouve qu'ils sont
ils s'en servent un petit peu trop là en
ce moment malheureusement il est plutôt
négatif quoi va de manière générale je
craque et la police française elle est
là pour faire respecter les lois et pour
faire régner l'ordre dans la société
on peut pas dit que la police française
les assists mais on peut encore
comprendre qu'ils aient des agents de la
police qui sont racistes ça c'est ça ces
contrats en fait alors qu'on me dit de
la police c'est bien gentil moi ce que
je sais la personne non en tant que
policier c'est pas la police en général
c'est la personne que je vois derrière
moi la police n'avait pas raciste ce
sont les personnes qui a derrière je
peux faire des généralités pour moi ça
sert à rien il ya des violences
policières depuis quelques années et que
l a du mal à reconnaître et à
s'autodiscipliner dans ses rangs non
mais c'est pas forcément de sa faute
c'est la faute à l'état qui donne pas
forcément d instruction ni des
formations adéquates
j'ai un avis totalement neutre je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de policiers qui font
bien leur travail qui a quelques brebis
galeuses qui comme dans tous les corps
de métiers bas fond des choses qui sont
un peu moins bien voilà c'est bien c'est
bien
que les gens se mobilisent pour dénoncer
des situations discrimination qui n'ont
que trop duré et pour en parler nous
sommes avec jean michel faubert avec
député la république en marge de la 8ème
circonscription de seine-et-marne ancien
patron du raid dont soir jean-michel à
fauvergue merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france pour réagir donc à
cette conférence de presse de christophe
castaner aujourd'hui pour vous est ce
que le ministre de l'intérieur a trouvé
les mots justes il a été à la hauteur de
la situation pour calmer les esprits
aujourd'hui il me semble que le ministre
l'intérieur a fait les annonces un
certain nombre d'annoncés qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait faire certaines sondes
plus intéressante que l'autre il faut le
reconnaître et sommes un certain nombre
de députés dans la majorité en
particulier députés dans un groupe de
sécurité de la majorité que je co anime
qui qui avons proposé un certain nombre
de choses et on voit que dans les propos
de christophe castaner ces choses là
sont repris en particulier les propos
qu'il a dit sur l'inspection générale de
la police nationale l'inspection
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
dont on voudrait qu'elle soit en ce qui
nous concerne nous en tout cas qu'elle
soit beaucoup plus autonomes beaucoup
plus indépendantes ou du moins qu'elles
dépendent du du du parlement et quelle
voix laquelle il est nécessaire à un
certain moment de marquer la rupture
entre un service enquêteur qui
appartient à la police nationale
actuellement et les enquêtes qu'il fait
donc un peu plus d'indépendance c'est
quelque chose de plutôt pas mal
c'est un voeu pieux sa jean-michel
fauvergue justement plus d'indépendance
pour le l'igpn on sait quel point il est
compliqué de réformer ce type
d'administration c'est toujours très
lourd ça vous semble vraiment réalisable
vous avez raison de le dire c'est
compliqué de transformer les
administrations et surtout au ministère
de l'intérieur où les administrations
ont beaucoup beaucoup de poids
énormément de poids aujourd'hui les
annonces café christophe castaner sondés
annoncent qu'ils vont dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire la prise de pouvoir par le
politique qui impose les choses qui est
obligé d'imposer les choses mais qu'il
les aime pompiers qui les imposent et ça
c'est quelque chose de nouveau jeu
j'espère y voit quand même une
une dynamique qui ira dans le sens de la
restructuration non pas uniquement pour
le problème pour on est en train de le
traiter en ce moment mais aussi pour
l'ensemble de la police et la
gendarmerie nationale et pour aller de
manière très très volontaire vers une
police de laon du 21e siècle avec en
particulier une police au service des
citoyens qu'on appelle la police de
sécurité du quotidien et que je vous
et qu'on a qu'on a mis en place déjà
depuis deux ans mais dont on voudrait
voir les impacts de plus en plus rapide
parce que c'est cette police là qui sera
au qui doit être au contact de nos
citoyens pour pour parler avec eux pour
pour éviter tout type de problème que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
alors christophe castaner veut que
chaque soupçons avérés de racisme je
cite dans la police entraîne une
suspension je veux une tolérance zéro a
dit ministre de l'intérieur le
rassemblement national a réagi
aujourd'hui il estime que le rôle d'un
ministre de l'intérieur c'est
précisément de soutenir la police le
parti accuse emmanuel macron et
christophe castaner de lâcher en clair
la gendarmerie et la police vous
l'ancien policier
qu'en pensez vous écoutez si vous m'avez
fait venir aujourd'hui c'est parce que
effectivement je suis à la fois ancien
policier hommes politiques
donc je peux avoir une expérience
intéressant dans ce domaine là et je
peux vous dire qu'en tant qu'ancien chef
de la police g
g
eu à traiter des affaires de très peu
mais jésus à traiter d'affaires de
policiers qui étaient racistes dans tous
les sens d'ailleurs attendre à 6 ans
tous les sens qui était qu'ils étaient
des policiers violents qu'ils étaient
des policiers pour certains voleurs etc
mais ce que je veux ce que je vais vous
dire c'est qu'il y en a très peu et qu'à
chaque fois on les a traité avec des
procédures administratives des policiers
des procédures judiciaires et que ces
procédures là ont abouti à des sanctions
les sanctions à la fois jeudi
administratives les sanctions pénales
donc on est on est bien bien évidemment
que pour répondre totalement à votre
question les politiques les politiques
et en particulier qui sont aux affaires
sont dans leur rôle en exigent aussi que
l'ap que la police et la gendarmerie et
je partage totalement cette cette idée
là la police et la gendarmerie soient
exemplaires mais ils sont dans leur rôle
aussi quand ils disent que attention on
est dans un état français on n'est pas
dans un état raciste
on n'est pas dans une avec une police
raciste et on doit aussi respecter la
justice actuellement il ya des vents
mauvais qui voudraient où il ya un
versement d'une inversion des valeurs on
accuse le policier on accuse le
magistrat on accuse les représentants de
l'autorité
c'est quelque chose que l'on doit
rétablir remettre dans le bon sens il y
a je le répète des gens qui sont dans
toutes les professions et dans la baie
la police et la gendarmerie n'y échappe
pas des gens une poignée de gens qui ne
sont pas au niveau de leurs fonctions
cela on doit les on doit on doit les
faire partir de là delà de cette
profession là mais l'ensemble l'ensemble
la police et la gendarmerie et de la
justice sont au service des citoyens
français et votre reportage le dit bien
à bordeaux où les citoyens bordelais le
disent dans votre reporter jean michel
faubert tout même effectivement tout le
monde s'accorde à dire là il ya des
brebis galeuses
il ya forcément comme dans la société
des policiers racistes comme il ya des
gens racistes dans la société n'est pas
le sentiment parfois quelques policiers
deviennent aussi les boucs émissaires là
d'une société qui va mal
l'illustration voilà deux du chômage de
la misère économique surtout après cette
crise terrible que nous venons vivre le
travail de police et un travail très
très difficile très dur très délicat
parce que effectivement un certain
moment les policiers se transmettent de
sauveur et 2 et 2 et de personnes qui
rendent service et qui assurent la
sécurité de tous vont se transformer
effectivement en particulier sur des
manifestations violentes comme bouc
émissaire de la part de manifestants par
exemple qui sont très violents qui vont
s'en prendre à eux parce qu'ils s'en
prennent ils s'en prennent à l'état et
face à eux ils ont des policiers qui
représente l'état selon eux est
effectivement à ce moment là les
policiers passent pour des boucs
émissaires et bien c'est tout ça qu'il
faut faire changer aussi dans les
mentalités
on doit pas pouvoir quand on est
policier on doit pas vivre cet ascenseur
émotionnel qui fait que le lundi on va
être applaudi par toute la population
parce que vous avez sauvé des otages et
parce que la population était en grand
danger et les policiers se sont
sacrifiés et j'en sais quelque chose et
le samedi se faire insulter par des
hordes de manifestants déchaînés
manipulés qui vont qui vont vouloir
casser du flic ou casser du gendarme et
sa selle c'est vraiment pas possible il
faut aussi il faut aussi que la
population française dans son entièreté
fasse aussi son mea culpa là dessus et
réfléchissent à ces situations là qui
met en porte-à-faux l'ensemble non
seulement un policier gendarme mais
l'ensemble des professions d'autorité
merci beaucoup jean-michel fauvergue
député la 8e circonscription
seine-et-marne ancien patron du raid
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france c'est une note secrète du chef de
file des députés la reine gilles
legendre adresse
macron est révélée par l'hebdomadaire
marianne met le feu aux poudres
un document dans lequel on trouvera les
pistes du chef de file sur le catherine
d'un éventuel nouveau gouvernement
le maire souhaite à matignon
questionnaire à la défense le drian à
l'intérieur et manuel valls aux affaires
étrangères mais là où le bât blesse
c'est sur le remplacement d'edouard
philippe qui se révèlent notamment en
populaire auprès de nombreux marcheurs
c'est en tout cas
gilles legendre qui se retrouve
maintenant sous le feu des critiques et
l issue de la crise sanitaire à deux ans
de la présidentielle après les
municipales le gouvernement doit-il être
remanié est ce nécessaire quel intérêt
et pour qui est il des noms qui font
consensus et sera l'objet
c'est plutôt l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir pour en parler
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis poulain cofondateur du monde
moderne bonsoir alexis poulain à ses
côtés francine ce palombes y président
de la confédération des commerçants ex
candidats à l'arrêt main aux
législatives 2010 est en lozère bonsoir
à vous aussi francis talons by merci
d'être avec nous alors avant de
commencer à discuter 1 messieurs voici
ce sondage instructif un étude aux hawks
apparu il y a quatre jours à peine une
majorité de français souhaite un
remaniement 64% et surtout un changement
de politique c'est pas étonnant alexis
poulain c'est votre souhait aussi oui
c'est pas étonnant enfin on peut voir
que ça fait quand même longtemps qu'il
ya une contestation profonde que ce soit
celle pour la réforme des retraites
l'assurance chômage et les
manifestations du gilet jaune maintenant
ces manifestations blacklight matters
contre le racisme et les violences
policières
ça fait longtemps que le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron en fait pose problème à
nombreux français parce qu'il est dans
la volonté de ne pas écouter de ne pas
dialoguer malgré ces annonces un ou une
dit toujours qu'il est dans le dialogue
il organisait un grand débat mais
c'était sa parole qui était mise en
scène par l'apa les changes en fait
qu'il pouvait y avoir je crois qu'il ya
une vraie fatigue de ce gouvernement
mais à partir du moment où c'est lui qui
choisit on ne peut pas attendre
grand-chose déjà quand on voit la note
de gilles legendre auquel vous faisait
référence
on voit quoi un jeu en fête d'enfant
gâté qui s'amuse à changer de poste au
sein d'un gouvernement a essayé de
monter de monter en grade et pourquoi
parce que quand emmanuel macron créé la
république en marche ce n'est pas un
parti ça n'existe pas donc il réunit en
fait des gens issus de la société civile
qui n'ont pas de carrière politique ou
bien des ambitieux des carriéristes de
la politique qui eux sont prêts à tout
prêt à trahir leur parti c'est le cas de
roland berger par exemple prêt à toutes
les concessions possibles pour monter
toujours monter et qui font leur auto
promotion c'est le cas de laëtitia via
qui voit là à d'abord une fois élu
député pour principe de vérifier sa
fiche wikipédia de faire sa pub c'est le
cas de marouane chamakh
maintenant claironne sur tous les
plateaux qu'elle veut plus un surtout
que l'on pense elle ne veut pas être
premier ministre non c'est encore trop
tôt mais elle entend bien durer
longtemps dans la carrière politique
donc ces affairistes ces carriéristes
ils sont entre eux ils font sur des
petits bouts de papier leur gouvernement
idéal ça va pas changer la vie des
français ça va pas changer les
politiques d'une égalité ça ne va pas
plus loin
francis palombe est important vous que
ça change son gouvernement où finalement
ça va pas changer grand chose comme nous
le dit entre les lignes
alexis poulain puisque par définition
emmanuel macron voilà va faire une forme
de deux changements cosmétiques entre
ses troupes
vous souhaitez vous en tout cas voir des
nouvelles têtes
écoutez moi je vais me prononcer
différemment que monsieur poulet il
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention je
salue ce soir très heureux d'être
interviewés en même temps que lui
bien évidemment moi je suis un
représentant professionnel je suis en
quelque sorte un syndicat professionnel
qui rassemble des fédérations
professionnelles de manche
essentiellement des très petits
commerçants de moins de onze salariés et
qui sont confrontées vous le savez
depuis plusieurs mois à une crise
profonde et ils ont été très affectés
ils sont arrivés au moment où le virus
est arrivé
eh bien les entreprises pour beaucoup
les très petites étaient déjà épuisés
épuisé économiquement donc de ce plat
est arrivée la crise de kobe 19 et je ne
dois de faire le point de la situation
turin quand directement économique par
rapport aux commerces aux commerçants et
aux très petites entreprises le pouvoir
face à la situation le ministre de
l'économie
bruno le maire et des membres du
gouvernement comme le ministère du
travail et d'autres ont pris la
situation en main et ont voulu à tout
prix éviter des fake et on voulu éviter
que le commerce c'est cool
ça aurait peut être le cas à de recettes
pas de charge
pas de charge pas de recette ça a été le
mot mètres plus haut niveau bruno le
maire a peut-être fait un bon job
française palombie moi personnellement
je constate et je suis pas là pour
valoriser plus que qu'un autre en
politique je suis pas un homme politique
vous avez rappelé quelque chose me
concernant mais qui remonte à quelques
années maintenant et j'ai bien compris
que un syndicat professionnel ne pouvait
pas être politisée
sinon il doit démissionner sinon je dois
me retirer de mon poste demandé que ma
démission
non je dis que bruno le maire je
souhaite qu'il reste aux manettes de
l'économie parce que par rapport aux
entreprises
il a un réalisme il a un pragmatisme et
y largement fort ils ne veulent pas de
faillite sous son ministère
il l'a dit et les premières réunions de
crise auxquels j'ai assistés et assisté
à toutes les réunions
je n'ai pas toujours été d'accord avec
le pouvoir j'ai demandé plus pour les
très petites entreprises et je
demanderai encore davantage je demande à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui
malgré de déconfinement qu'on continue à
soutenir j'ai pas d'y assister à
soutenir les entreprises tpe moins de
onze ou 100 salariés sont fragiles
réaffecter mais qui constitue en termes
de nombre par rapport au commerce en
général 98%
donc pas de complexe nous devons
continuer les centres villes doivent se
revitaliser ce gouvernement mis en place
un ministère de la cohésion des
territoires
là je suis particulièrement favorable et
je travaille
harris et ministère pour améliorer
améliorer revitaliser je suis en train
de porter une pétition est très
importante contre amazon parce que c'est
un scandale de laisser se développer des
entrepôts amazon qui vont tuer le
commerce de proximité et de commerces de
périphérie également voyez que il y
avait en avant
ont pris parce que c'est un débat et
pardonnez-moi francis palombes iront
comprend face aux palombes vu ses
fonctions juges et c'est bien normal
dans le sous la forme du prisme de cette
gestion économique de la crise du duc au
vide
c'est justement le point lexsi poulain
tout ce gouvernement va être jugé à
l'aune de cette crise sanitaire qu'on
vient de vivre sachant qu'il ya une
commission d' enquête sur cette gestion
il ya beaucoup de ministres qui sont mis
en cause aujourd'hui il faut faire table
rase du passé en quelque sorte c'est ça
l'intérêt des manuels macron aujourd'hui
de tourner la page de cette crise
sanitaire
mais son intérêt il est surtout de
sauver son quinquennat parce qu'il reste
à sauver parce que oui monsieur
palombière raison les petites
entreprises les tpe pme sont le poumon
de l'emploi dans ce pays
et heureusement qu'on a des aides et
qu'on les aide mais il faut aller plus
loin il faut que les bailleurs jours de
jeu que les banques jouent le jeu qu'on
évite massivement les faillites mais
pourquoi on en arrive là pour qu'on en
arrive là parce que la crise sanitaire
n'a pas été géré parce qu'au moment où
on aurait pu choisir d'avoir des masques
massivement au moment où il le fallait
on n'en a pas eu
parce qu'au moment où il aurait fallu
testé massivement on n'a pas testé et
aujourd'hui encore libérant nous dit
finalement frappe à 700000 thèse par
semaine parce que le virus ne circule
plus trop donc la gestion sanitaire a
été calamiteuse calamiteuse et on s'est
retrouvé avec un équipement évidemment
bien sûr et on s'est retrouvé avec un
confinement qui va être la
catastrophique en terme économique donc
de a à z que ce soit emmanuel macron son
gouvernement la gestion a été
catastrophique qu'on ne nous dise pas le
contraire nous en a nous en vivons
aujourd'hui le problème est alors ils
vont faire ce qu'ils peuvent pour sauver
leur image publique pour sauver leur
poste et pour sauver ce qui peuvent
sauver mais on est dans le mur parce que
les mauvais choix ont été faits par les
gens aux commandes
aucun pays au monde n'a eu sa ministre
de la santé qui a démissionné pour faire
une campagne politique
aucun pays au monde a menti sur les
masques aucun pays au monde à tarder à
mettre en place le confinement ou à
faire les clusters de manière beaucoup
plus strictes pour éviter que le virus
ne se répande sur le territoire donc
qu'on arrête avec cette légende de faire
croire que la gestion de crise a été
correcte elle est très créative critique
à l'excellent poulain mais tout de même
pardonnez moi ça ce que j'avance dourdan
dans le débat excusez moi il ya cette
suite du sondage que je voulais vous
montrer un vous le savez pas de
changement de premier ministre pour les
français deux français sur trois 65%
voudrait bien qu edouard philippe reste
à matignon
ça vous étonne safran si ce plombier
essayons de faire des réponses courtes
pour se laisser la parole parce qu'on
arrive à la fin de ce débat alors c'est
vrai qu'on critique beaucoup la gestion
lectrice de la part du gouvernement mais
dans le fond edouard philippe a plutôt
pris des galons lors de cette crise
ducobu 19 contrairement emmanuel macron
bon ce n'est pas de matin revenant parce
que je n'ai pas le droit de juger qui
que ce soit mais c'est vrai que les
douars philippe est resté toujours très
réservé très sobre pendant ses discours
il n'a pas vendu la peau de l'ours avant
de l'avoir tué comme on dit suivant une
expression bien française c'est vrai que
il a expliqué beaucoup alors je pense
que les français ayant très peur parce
que nous avons eu peur pour notre santé
nous avons eu peur pour nos proches nous
avons eu peur de perdre la vie et ses
barrières c'est pour cette raison que le
déconfinement boîte est conçu et qui a
une poursuite des règles malgré que on
est tiraillé avec le souci est la
volonté que ça ceux des consignes
vraiment et que les entreprises
repartent
imaginez les restaurants c'est
catastrophique pour eux j'ai deux
fédérations professionnelles qui a qui
parlent de restauration alors comme pour
les voyez vous avez la position non pas
d'un syndicaliste du commerce et bien
évidemment pour un syndicaliste du
commerce
il faut sauver sur le plan économique
les entreprises
moi vous savez ici dans une prochaine
interview sur votre plateau que nous
avons 50 100 200 sites au sein de la
confédération des commerçants de france
je serais vraiment très affecté triste
vraiment à vous serez très malheureux et
on serait évidemment pour ces
entreprises alexis voulant le mot de la
fin sur voir ce bénéfique quand même
d'edouard philippe que peut faire
emmanuel macron est-ce qu'il a intérêt à
se débarrasser de ce premier ministre
populaire qui pourrait peut-être se
présenter contre lui en 2022 oui ça
reste clairement aujourd'hui une grande
question qui sera qui pourrait être le
candidat de la droite face à emmanuel
macron s'il se représentait il n'est pas
sûr on est loin en 2022 et évidemment
edouard philippe paré comme très
légitime il a été celui qui a paru le
plus compétent dans cette crise le plus
sobre
effectivement et le plus à l écoute vous
aviez en face de lui un président qui
était totalement déconnecté qui parlait
d'une bière qui parlait de chevaucher le
tigre qui faisait des apparitions
lunaire on ne comprenait pas vraiment ce
qu'il voulait dire qu'il n'utilisait pas
les mots et lui arrivait avec les
professionnels de la santé avec les
ministres pour expliquer qu'elle était
le plan hockey ce qu'il pouvait faire
donc de loin c'est lui qui n'est pas
apparu le plus compétent est celui en
charge en commandes de cette crise donc
il a été celui qui a bénéficié du
meilleur de la meilleure image
maintenant est-ce que c'est mieux pour
lui de rester et de continuer dans ce
quinquennat étrange qu'est celui d'
emmanuel macron ou bien de se retirer
s'il est élu au havre et de préparer de
là bas ce qui sera sa candidature pour
2022 s'il souhaite se présenter ça reste
une stratégie politique personnelle qui
sera la sienne on est dans la cinquième
donc c'est une stratégie de personnes
avant de l'idée mais la question mérite
d'être posée et on la suivra évidemment
avec vous merci beaucoup à tous les deux
avec six poulains francis palombes il
marque une très petite
une courte pause plus tôt et on se
retrouve pour parler des états unis où
l'émotion reste palpable après la mort
de georges floyd ancien policier accusé
de l'avoir tuée comparaît pour la
première fois devant la justice du
minnesota on ira ensuite en allemagne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
20h30 heure française sur rt france aux
états unis les obsèques de giorgio floyd
auront lieu demain houston la situation
semble s'apaiser dans le pays après
plusieurs jours d'émeutes consécutives à
sa mort cet afro américain de 46 ans a
été tué par un policier blanc le 25 mai
des règles chauvin inculpé de meurtre a
comparu aujourd'hui pour la première
fois devant un juge lors d'une audience
de procédure organisée par vidéo
une caution d'un million de dollars a
été fixé il y aura par ailleurs une
réforme profonde de la police de
minneapolis une décision du conseil
municipal et black lips matters en
français la vie des noirs compte c'est
donc ce slogan qui a resurgi avec cette
affaire georgia flou mais qui
malheureusement est loin d'être utilisé
pour la première fois cécilia chaume
désormais visible du ciel sur la route
de la maison blanche le slogan
blacklight matters est le symbole de la
lutte contre la haine raciale et les
violences policières à l'initiative de
la mer de washington cette portion de
route sera même bientôt rebaptisé la
blake lively matters plaza je pense que
c'est génial
le fait que la ville les faits et que ce
soit si proche de l'endroit où se cache
le garçon au bunker je pense que c'est
assez symbolique
vous savez courir vers le président
toute sa haine je pense que c'est tout
simplement incroyable et merveilleux
c'est bouleversant en fait aux états
unis et partout dans le monde
trois mots sur toutes les banderoles sur
les visages parfois lévy noir compte
au départ c'est alicia garza
éditorialistes et militante qui lance un
hashtag mot clé sur internet
nous sommes le 13 juillet 2013 sous la
présidence obama
l'auteur vient d'apprendre
l'acquittement du meurtrier de trêve
martin un afro-américain de 17 ans elle
publie un billet d'humeur black people
as love you à l'os à la vie ce matin
personne noire je vous aime je nous
aiment nos vies compte une artiste et
activiste patrice kahn que leur celui
répond blake lively matters le slogan
est lancé l'année suivante
eric garner et être anglais à new york
par un policier
michael braun d'un adolescent noir de 18
ans non-armés est abattu par un policier
blanc à ferguson dans le missouri
blacklight matters devient un mouvement
et organise ses premières manifestations
contre le racisme dans les forces de
l'ordre suivent de nombreuses actions
non violentes des die in mettant en
scène des militants coucher au sol
l'occupation de centres commerciaux ou
encore le blocage de routes ou de train
[Musique]
je vais vous dire c'est un moment
historique un moment nécessaire nous a
tendu un moment comme celui ci où les
gens porterait enfin leur attention sur
les injustices m qui affecte et
affligent la communauté noire depuis
bien trop longtemps
depuis des générations et des
générations sur son site internet black
live matters se définit comme un
collectif de libérateur qui croient en
un mouvement inclusif sans figure
dirigeante ni structure organisée de
l'avis de nombreux observateurs il
s'agirait d'une mouvance un cri de
ralliement contre les injustices et la
discrimination
souvent comparé au mouvement des droits
civiques des années 60
blacklight matters inclut les luttes
contre d'autres formes de discrimination
l'idéologie de base vise à mettre fin à
la suprématie blanche il est ouvert aux
personnes queer transgenres et si genre
si à l'origine il s'agit de
bord de lutter contre la brutalité
policière sa portée plus large
il reprend là où le mouvement des droits
civiques s'est arrêté parmi les
critiques certains pointent une forme de
radicalité en 2016 en particulier quand
un réserviste noir de l'armée américaine
ouvre le feu sur cinq policiers blancs
en se réclamant de blacklight matters à
ce moment sont créés les hashtag alive
matters toutes les vicomtes ou encore
blue lines matin en solidarité avec la
police un constat aujourd'hui black
cloud matters est scandé par toutes
sortes de personnes âges sexes et
couleurs de peau partout sur le globe
et pour en parler nous sommes avec allen
or avocat bonsoir l énorme merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france l'ex
policier donc un derek chauvin qui
comparaît devant la justice pour la
première fois que doit-on attendre de ce
procès on imagina à haut risque très
symbolique aux états unis qui peut même
peut-être changer les choses dans un
sens comme dans l'autre
effectivement il pourrait changer les
choses au niveau du système judiciaire
en matière d'immunité de la police mais
l'impact social des risques à s'applique
déjà il ya eu beaucoup de changements
dans nos conversations autour de la
brutalité policière et le tour de l'est
la vie des noirs aux états unis on a pu
voir qu à minneapolis
il change la façon de maintenir l'ordre
on sait on dit souvent que la police est
intouchable aux états unis
très soutenu notamment par les syndicats
est ce qu'il y aura vraiment selon vous
un tournant désormais après cette
affaire un changement dans les états
d'esprit il ya un très large mouvement
de réduction des financements de la
police le conseil municipal de l'una
police a voté hier afin de démonter la
police a donc effectivement c'est déjà
du changement et vous l'avez vu dans les
rues les conversations change les
démocrates ce matin ont proposé un
projet de loi qui pourrait ne pas
réussir mais qui traite ce sujet alors
effectivement la ville de minneapolis
qui annonce vouloir je suis démanteler
sa police car elle n'est pas réformable
c'est une première vous vous êtes en
lien une telle décision qu'elles vont en
être les conséquences
les conséquences pourraient être très
positive nous vivons dans une société où
la police peut parfois créer du danger
et des crimes en plus car ce marteau
peut s'abattre sur beaucoup de personnes
donc plutôt que la police ont pour avoir
besoin par exemple d'où les travailleurs
sociaux d'autres moyens de gérer les
problèmes par exemple dans la sphère
georges flotte il s'agissait d'un faux
billets et il ya beaucoup de vandalisme
de deux incendies et
de troubles civique pour c'est ce billet
ce faux billets cela pourrait aurait pu
être géré très différemment alors vous
dites oui on peut trouver une
alternative à la police effectivement
elle va être démantelée aujourd'hui
comment on pourrait évoluer les choses
une autre police autrement vous nous
dites
effectivement il s'agirait d'un système
social différent souvent dans les écoles
par exemple les écoles privées ou dans
certains s'attendent quartier on trouve
d'autres façons de gérer les situations
et par exemple au sein de larges famille
on a un père une mère qui ils font
respecter la paix dans la sphère lui
mais il ya d'autres façons de et de
sanctionner les enfants que le dell de
les punir
c'est la même chose avec la police on
pourrait retrouver à des personnes qui
peuvent contrôler la communauté sans
arrêter les gens l'arrestation
c'est au centre du système policier non
aux états unis on a plus de prisonniers
que tout autre pays du monde et plus de
personnes de couleur donc cela ne peut
plus exister
emprisonné quelqu'un ne résout pas les
plans sociaux au sein de notre société
et ne résout pas les problèmes
d'inégalité car la plupart des
prisonniers sont des noirs alors qu'ils
représentent moins de 20% du total de la
population américaine en france ya
souvent un débat sur ce qu'on appelle la
police de proximité une police qui est
voilà sur le terrain au contact
notamment la population avec qui parfois
justement ça se passe mal est-ce qu'il
est souhaitable justement qui est cette
police selon une police qui est au
contact même de la population c'est ce
projet de loi démocrate que la police
soit une police de fac santé
et effectivement ses proches de la
communauté - on a deux problèmes parce
que la personne arrêtée est familière
aux policiers et il ya donc moins de
problèmes grâce à cette reconnaissance
on est allé à l'école avec le personnes
du voisinage
il les connaît mieux et on est plus à
même de calmer la situation
ce n'est pas le cas aux états unis il
n'y a pas de points communs entre la
police et la population il n'y a pas de
communauté merci beaucoup annoncent
avoir était avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors que l'ex-policier derek
chauvin comparaît devant la justice pour
la première fois devant la justice
évidemment du minnesota merci à vous
donald trump envisagerait de réduire le
nombre de militaires déployés en
allemagne informations du wall street
journal
le pays est le principal ancrage des
forces américaines de l'otan ce retrait
inquiète donc les allemands un risque
pour la sécurité est un coup dur pour
les relations germano américaines
rania berrada tout part d'un article du
wall street journal affirmant que donald
trump a ordonné au pentagone de réduire
à 25 mille le nombre de militaires
présents en allemagne
un article qui suscite l'inquiétude
outre-rhin d'autant que la maison
blanche et le pentagone se refuse à
confirmer ou infirmer cette information
le ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères s'il assure que cette
présence militaire sert les deux parties
avoue que les relations ne sont pas au
beau fixe
nous apprécions la coopération avec les
forces armées américaines qui a grandi
au long des décennies
elle est dans l'intérêt de nos deux pays
nous sommes deux proches partenaires au
sein de l'alliance transatlantique
mais c'est compliqué il faut dire que
cet article survient dans un contexte de
tensions entre le gouvernement américain
et ses alliés européens au sein de
l'otan washington estime notamment que
berlin ne dépense pas assez pour sa
propre défense
actuellement quelques trente quatre
mille cinq cents soldats vivent avec
leurs familles sur une des 21 une base
militaire américaine en allemagne le
départ de 9500 militaire équivaudrait à
réduire
significativement l'engagement américain
dans la défense européenne dans le cadre
de l'otan une décision dangereuse estime
dans un tweet un ancien chef des forces
terrestres américaines en europe comme
j'ai été fortement impliqué dans les
deux dernières réductions structurelles
de l'armée de terre américaine en europe
je peux maintenant le dire publiquement
c'est dangereux ça démontre un manque de
vision et ça va se heurter au refus du
congrès et c'est un cadeau fait à la
russie qui va fragiliser nos alliances
mais peut-être aussi en créer de
nouvelles
dès le lendemain de la publication de
l'article le premier ministre polonais a
déclaré espérer qu'une partie des
soldats américains retiraient
d'allemagne seront installés en pologne
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales dont soir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors pourquoi cette décision si elle
est avérée intervient tél maintenant
homme et je crois que c'était un
avertissement très sérieux envoyé par
donald trump à madame merkel est donc à
l'allemagne d'abord parce que comme ça
et il vient votre sujet l'allemagne ne
dépense pas assez pour sa défense la
l'économie la plus développée
l'europe est elle est loin d'atteindre
le seuil de 2% qui a été fixée d'un
commun accord au sein de l'otan mais
aussi parce que madame merkel a vexé
monsieur trump sur plusieurs sujets
d'abord elle poursuit son projet de nord
stream 2 le gazoduc entre la russie et
l'allemagne que d'ailleurs la france
soutient aussi et monsieur trump - pour
des raisons stratégiques que pour vendre
du gaz naturel liquéfié américains
s'opposent à 16 à cette construction
d'un gazoduc
ensuite madame merkel a probablement
vexé monsieur trump en lui disant il ya
quelques semaines que finalement elle
n'irait pas un g7 s'il se tenait à
cambes évident au mois de juin g7
élargie et puis aussi plus récemment la
semaine dernière
r elle a parlé d'un meurtre raciste à
propos en effet de la mort 2
le monsieur lorsque vous l'avez décrit
tout à l'heure et puis enfin peut-être
dernière chose monsieur trump sait
pertinemment que l'allemagne va prendre
la présidence de l'union européenne le
1er juillet prochain et qu'elle a comme
projet pendant ce dernier semestre de
l'année 2020 de forger une position
commune de l'union européenne vis-à-vis
de la chine et d'un certain nombre
d'autres pays qui serait différente de
la position américaine
quelles seraient les conséquences
précisément pour l'allemagne les
conséquences c'est d'abord que les
allemands et bien qu'on les aime donc la
première conséquence c'est que
l'allemagne aurait les présidents
l'impression d'un désamour de la part
des états unis
ce qui est grave probablement pour le
gouvernement allemand
et puis par ailleurs 9500 soldats avec
les familles ça fait à peu près trente
mille personnes ça fait à peu près ça
fait à peu près 3000 personnes et 3000
personnes qui vivent dans les villages
qui sont proches de leurs bases
militaires et qui font des dépenses
naturellement donc ça fera comme à
chaque fois qu une garnison s'en va ça
fera des dégâts dans l'économie locale
et puis je crois aussi que ça provoque
un débat à l'intérieur de la classe
politique allemande est que ce débat
commence à faire des dégâts on a assisté
tout à l'heure le ministre des affaires
étrangères mais la ministre la défense
aussi s'est exprimé d'ailleurs dans le
même sens que le secrétaire général de
l'otan monsieur stoltenberg en disant
que la défense de l'allemagne c'était
aussi la défense des états unis et que
c'était un système global
donc on entre dans un débat que
heureusement nous n'avons pas à avoir en
france puisque depuis 54 ans il n'y a
plus de bases américaines en france
alors qu'adobe blanchemaison quelles
pourraient être les futures relations
précisément entre l'allemagne et les
états unis
je crois que ça ne changera pas grand
chose parce que ce n'est pas parce qu'on
va retirer 9500 soldats américains que
les choses changent beaucoup d'ailleurs
dans l'article que
vous avez cité on dit que l'amérique
maintiendrait 25 mille hommes en
allemagne 25 mille hommes c'est quand
même un seuil très important qui permet
de faire en sorte que si l'allemagne
était attaquée bien entendu les états
unis seraient nécessairement impliquer
donc je pense que ça ne tient ça ne
changera pas grand chose sauf que en
effet les allemands peuvent avoir
l'impression que ceci n'est qu'une
première étape qui sera suivie d'autres
étapes et que progressivement on
arrivera à une situation où la garantie
de l'article 5 de la charte de l'otan ne
sera plus crédible c'est à dire
l'engagement automatique des états unis
si l'allemagne et par conséquent et
l'europe étaient attaqués un projet
militaire européen commun la création
d'une armée européenne comme emmanuel
macron la plaie de ses voeux en 2017
ce projet at il une chance d'aboutir à
très long terme mais à court terme de
toute façon le temps subsiste personne
ne propose le démantèlement de l'otan
pas même monsieur trump et les états
unis ont trop d'intérêt et par
conséquent l'alliance atlantique va
demeurer elle va évoluer mais elle va
elle va demeurer alors par contre la
proposition faite par le président
français et je crois a accepté dans son
principe par madame merkel à savoir
d'élaborer une stratégie européenne qui
est une certaine autonomie avec des
instruments d'analysé qui soit
proprement européen
ceci est en cours et va se développer on
est encore très loin d'une armée
européenne plus grande coordination
entre les armées nationales en europe
merci candeur blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales de nous avoir
apporté votre analyse en belgique cafés
et restaurants fermés depuis le 13 mars
minuit ont été autorisés à rouvrir leurs
portes ce matin le virus le cornac virus
a fait près de dix mille morts dans ce
pays de plus de 11 millions d'habitants
c'est l'une des mortalités les plus
zélés
et au monde rapporté à la population
totale fermée pendant environ trois mois
les cafés belges ont particulièrement
souffert
et pour leur venir en aide le
gouvernement belge a annoncé vendredi
une réduction de la tva à 6% jusqu'à la
fin de l'année à l'exception des
boissons alcoolisées les clients étaient
eux ravis ce matin bruxelles de
retrouver leur café le franchement
c'était peut-être j'ai remarqué après
que c'était la faute
une des choses les plus importantes pour
moi c'est vraiment de de sortir boire un
petit café le matin avant de commencer
mon travail
et ça ça me motive et toutes les années
ça me fait du bien ça fait du bien de
prendre le café l'extérieur parce que ça
fait trois mois aussi que je ne
travaille pas et donc forcément un
moment donné on a envie de faire autre
chose que de rester chez soi et
l'espagne entre dans la phase 2 du
déconfinement aujourd'hui 25 millions de
personnes sont concernées les
explications sur place avec leslie
singles à barcelone et madrid passe en
phase 2 du plan de déconfinement à
barcelone les plages sont de nouveau
accessibles les barcelonais peuvent se
baigner et s'y poser toute la journée
sans restriction d'horaire mais en
respectant les distances de sécurité et
par ailleurs du coup les plages feront
l'objet d'une haute surveillance
policière
des caméras seront même installé comme
vous pouvez le voir derrière moi alors
l'autre grand changement de la phase 2
c'est l'ouverture des centres
commerciaux et des grandes surfaces à 40
% de leur capacité d'accueil les clients
doivent entrer gantés et masqués du gel
hydro alcoolique est également à
disposition et les zones communes
restent fermés de leur côté l'intérieur
des restaurants mais aussi les cinémas
et théâtres peuvent ouvrir mais aussi
avec une capacité d'accueil limitée
certaines régions d'espagne sont déjà
dans la phase iii du plan de
déconfinement et le grand changement de
cette phase c'est l'ouverture des boîtes
de nuit et des bars nocturnes mais sans
piste de danse alors si le retour à la
normale est progressif en espagne le
gouvernement a déjà annoncé que le port
du masque sera obligatoire juste
à l'automne en cas de non respect les
habitants comme les touristes s'expose à
une amende de 100 euros
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur cette phase ii du
déconfinement en france cette fois ci
parents d'élèves entrepreneurs aux
restaurateurs souhaitent un
assouplissement des mesures sanitaires
l'état lui reste prudent et puis nous
parlerons des masques à l'industrie
française s'est mobilisée pour en
produire mais la production asiatique
joue les trouble fête
les invendus sont à son grand dam de la
filière textile
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et la faune karl de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait ça je n'ai pas d'une
décision invraisemblable pour vos ça
dépend telles valeurs on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes même
individuel avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura un débat éthique
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa part
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
l'afrique et compte 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça l'est
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'on
venait de sortir d'une épidémie à ebola
qui exige également la distanciation
social lavage des mains si on aura
affaire à deux épidémies aussi
dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronary ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président très pratique et le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
m
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer en soit vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck fall que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
près de six mois de comprendre ce qui se
passe tout l'enjeu de notre association
c'est construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à lévis mais quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils étaient pas préparés
mais les villes se sont connectés tout
de suite entre elles pour voir comment
elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques des matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles
comment est ce qu'elle trouve
transformée après la pandémie la crise
maintenant à fait bien comprendre qu'on
peut pas s'oublier des banlieues on peut
pas oublier les quartiers pauvres parce
que véritablement font partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas seulement d'elle même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait à gauche dans le projet politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
compte et très très grands défis face
auxquels nous sommes aimés en
particulier le défi québec et ses
conséquences et notamment une polémique
là c'est la première médaille en avoir
d'autres il faut qu'ils aient pris de
conscience collective
vraiment
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce 8
juin le déconfinement n'allons pas trop
vite plaide olivier ferrand si
l'épidémie marque le pas le ministre de
la santé ne souhaite pas accélérer le
rythme pour assouplir les mesures de
restriction l'obligation d'un protocole
sanitaires strictes dans les écoles où
l'interdiction des rassemblements depuis
le dix personnes dans l'espace public
reste de mise
près d'une semaine après le début de la
phase ii du déconfinement prochaine date
butoir ce sera le 22 juin
[Musique]
qui dit déconfinement dix masques si
cette denrée est un temps été rares on
s'en souvient il est désormais facile
d'en trouver même c'est un problème pour
l'industrie textile française qui a du
mal aujourd'hui à écouler son stock
l'assemblée nationale doit se pencher
sur cette question ce soir lors comment
notre pays il passé en quelques semaines
d'une pénurie à des stocks entiers qui
ne trouve pas preneur en train d'y
répondre
outre-manche sénat quarantaine la photo
coronavirus depuis minuit le royaume uni
en hausse 14 jours de mise à l'isolément
à tous les voyageurs étrangers arrivant
sur le sol britannique sous peine d'une
amende de 1000 livres et mesure décriée
notamment par les compagnies aériennes
une décision qui intervient dans un
contexte tendu avec l'union européenne
aux etats unis les obsèques de judge
floyd auront lieu demain à houston cet
homme afro américain de 46 ans asphyxié
lors d'une interpellation le 25 mai
dernier le policier responsable de sa
mort a comparu aujourd'hui devant la
justice du minnesota une caution d'un
million de dollars a été fixée est la
mairie elles promettent une réforme
profonde de son système policier
[Musique]
tout d'abord le bilan du corona virus
dans l'hexagone le nombre de personnes
en réanimation continue de baisser selon
la direction générale de la santé la
france en régissent 54 morts liés aux
kobe de 19 dans les hôpitaux ces
dernières 24 heures au total 29 mille
deux cent neuf personnes sont mortes
depuis le début de l'épidémie et des
bons chiffres qui illustrent une
circulation beaucoup moins rapide du
virus le ministre de la santé était en
déplacement de ce matin dans un centre
de dépistage argenteuil dans le val
d'oise
olivier ferrand a justement expliqué que
les 700 mille tests de dépistage prévu
par semaine ne seront finalement pas
effectué la situation s'améliore nous
avons beaucoup d'espoir que la situation
continue de s'améliorer dans le val
d'oise en ile-de-france comme sur le
reste du territoire national avec encore
des points d'alerté très fort notamment
en guyane ou à mayotte guyane où le
virus circule peu trop donc encore une
fois il faut avancer prudemment de façon
déterminée en mettant toutes les chances
de notre côté pour permettre aux
français de retrouver toute leur liberté
toute leur joie de vivre comme avant
mais sans laisser aucune chance au virus
de repartir c'est trop important donc
nous nous évaluons la situation au jour
le jour en fonction des indicateurs en
fonction aussi du niveau de saturation
de notre système de santé avec des gens
ici y compris des médecins qui vous
disent attention quand même attention
quand même
n'allons pas trop vite on a réussi à
gagner une bataille par l'effort de tous
une bataille qu'il était très difficile
de gagner on n'a pas encore gagné la
guerre donc vigilance alors le
déconfinement foti d' accélérer
calendrier les signaux sont ils au vert
ou au contraire comme d'un an temps de
la prudence reste bien de rigueur pour
en parler nous sommes avec bertrand
legrand médecins généralistes bonsoir
bertrand le grand merci d'être avec nous
à ses côtés marcel bénézet président de
la branche des cafés bars et brasseries
de l'organisation génie hcr bonsoir à
vous merci aussi d'être avec nous alors
on viens de l'entendre
certains notamment les professionnels
demandent une accélération du
déconfinement à la faveur des bons
chiffres d'autres comme le ministre de
la santé appelle à la
prudence que dit le médecin que vous
êtes bertrand legrand aujourd'hui l'a
pris dans prudence reste de mise c'est
important alors médecin par définition
cherche toujours la prudence 1 s'est
fait malheureusement un très classique
nous ont ce qu'on constate c'est que là
que l'épidémie diminué en intensité
ce qu'on constate c'est qu'elle circule
toujours c'est à dire que encore les
hier j'ai fait un test positif et ce
qu'on constate surtout c'est que si on a
dû confiner à cause de l'absence de
masques et à cause de l'absence de test
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'absence de
masques ou l'absence de test qui
pourrait nous emmener vers la deuxième
vague
c'est l'absence de port de masques par
la population et l'absence d'avoir
effectué des tests puisque comme vient
de le dire
olivier verrons nous n'atteindrons pas
les 700 mille tests
or pour trouver les derniers cas qui
pourrait faire flamber l'épidémie il
nous faudra bien faire un grand nombre
de tests sans obtenir de positif
il faut pas se fatiguer et il va falloir
continuer et persévérer pour y arriver
on reviendra sans ces mesures de
déconfinement ce que je voulais avoir
votre avis justement l'avis du médecin
faut-il accélérer ce déconfinement va
d'abord demander ce qu'il en pense à
marcel bénézet qui représentait cafés
bars brasseries notamment à paris on
sait que vous avez évidemment souffert
et vous continuez de souffrir surtout à
paris vous vous êtes parmi ceux qui
demandent une accélération même avant le
22 juin de ces mesures de déconfinement
tout à fait nous demandons-nous
l'ouverture ne le resteront en totalité
parce qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez ce
que je crains dans les jours à venir
dans les mois à venir
c'est la deuxième vague ça veut dire
qu'ils économique elle est déjà bien
entamée et ensuite psychologique parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des chefs
d'entreprises qui sont à bout qui n'en
peuvent plus quand on entend le
directeur du comité scientifique ilic on
peut lâcher il faut y aller que des
consignes mans est plus dangereux que le
décompte final on n'est pas dangereux et
surtout que le confinement serait
dangereux à la limite de rester chez soi
il faut tout lâcher les jeunes ont
besoin de s'amuser
aujourd'hui les restaurants sont vite
vous avez la météo bien sûr ils y sont
pour rien la météo n'est pas favorable
pour nos terrasses à paris et
aujourd'hui vous avez les établissements
qui sont vides il y en a même qui ont
ouvert mardi mercredi qui ont refermé
pour cause de clientèle parce que des
la même et à anvers 30% avec notre âme
et non salariés
la clientèle n'est pas au rendez vous il
ya un problème c'est la même chose il
faut pas penser que sur le littoral
les restaurants sont pleins ils ne sont
pas pleins aujourd'hui c'est difficile
de la météo marcel bénézet selon vous à
cause des mesures drastiques de du
protocole sanitaire on rappelle à mettre
entre les tables quand on se lève il
faut mettre un masque
c'est assez lourd alors à paris c'est
carrément interdit on le rappelle aussi
et d'ouvrir les restaurants l'intérieur
il ya que les terrasses qui le sont
jusqu'à 22 heures
les terrasses sont ouvertes et à 22
heures mêlant tir assez les terrasses de
classiques sont ouvertes jusqu'à c'était
la ferme du restaurant 2 heures du matin
j'étais à la fermeture
mais aujourd'hui c'est pas suffisant
quand vous ouvrez un restaurant et que
vous savez où laloubère un perdant de
l'argent c'est très compliqué nous
aujourd'hui pas là par la voix de mon
président monsieur didier chenet le
président national de l'ensemble de nos
données aux filières en nous avons fait
une lettre au président de la république
le premier ministre
nous demandons la plus rapidement
l'ouverture de nos est oubliée de nos
établissements
bien sûr à respecter il est très
important le protocole sanitaire
aujourd'hui ce qui peut nous nous
préserver de ceux de ce virus qui
circule encore et j'en suis conscient je
veux permettre au niveau de notre
personnel ni notre clientèle en danger
c'est de porter le port du masque quand
il est nécessaire et la distanciation
dans un certain lieu
vous avez aussi une étape ça vous va
vous oui ça va mais on peut on peut
arriver à travailler avec ça avec les
terrasses il va faire bon on peut
arriver mais aujourd'hui sur paris on
est carrément nos établissements sont
carrément fermé aujourd'hui c'est
dramatique
aujourd'hui vous avez les chefs
d'entreprises qui sont au bord de la
dépression moi je suis très sélectif
pour cause de ce qu'elle appelle la
troisième va mieux psychologiquement
parce que ça va être très compliqué
bertrand legrand votre avis justement
déjà sur cette accélération du
déconfinement le médecin que vous êtes
qui nous donne un dd bonne analyse ans
depuis le début de cette épidémie
qu'est ce qu'il en pense on peut
commencer à rouvrir les restaurants tout
en respectant les gestes barrière où il
ya quand même un danger
je l'avais dit il ya quelques semaines
le confinement c'est la sanction d'un
état qui n'a pas de masque et qui n'a
pas de test donc si nous n'avons pas de
masque et nous n'avons pas de test on se
doit d'être confiné aujourd'hui on a été
livré d'un plu à peu près un milliard de
tests de masques donc on a largement le
nombre de masques possible reste à faire
respecter le port du masque évidemment
et on a largement de quoi faire des
tests on en a 700 milles je remarque
jardon bertrand legrand mais c'est
intéressant olivier ferrand nous a dit
on va pas les utiliser parce que le
virus circule beaucoup moins alors ça c
est ce que vous aviez dit d'ailleurs ce
sera trop tard quand on aura les masques
et les tests effectivement vous pensé
quand même qu'il faudrait les utiliser
c'est quand même encore la solution les
tests ou chez obsolète mais c'est très
amusant olivier verrons a été sur une
position de tester les fantomatiques
puis après les peaux six armes
automatiques
puis les assemble automatique et
aujourd'hui je rends compte qu'il fera
pas capable de tester à la hauteur qu'il
faut pour mettre fin à l'épidémie
on a vu que l'épidémie pouvait partir
d'un seul cas donc effectivement si on
teste pas on va se retrouver avec un
redémarrage et leur démarrage de
l'épidémie c'est catastrophique puisque
si on a été pénalisé de sept semaines de
confinement enfin je pense que cette
semaine mais je suis je finis par en
perdre mon temps c'est inepte impossible
inacceptable de refaire cette semaine de
confinement on va pas se faire
sanctionner deux fois parce qu'on n'est
pas capable d'appliquer des mesures
normal et deuxième chose je pense qu'il
faut arrêter d'emmerder tout le monde
avec des mesures qui n'ont aucun sens
d'un point de vue médical
la distanciation social lui le problème
c'est l'aérosol isation du virus donc il
faut aérer
après les histoires de contact
aujourd'hui on sait quand même
relativement bien que c'est pas vraiment
un problème de portage de contact c'est
beaucoup plus de la réussite et de
l'aérosol isation donc à un grand rire
grand restaurant qui a de la hauteur
sous plafond qui est aérée qui assez qui
cause qui respectent les normes de
renouvellement d'air très sincèrement le
risque est assez faible c'est comme
quand on a interdit avec quelqu un l et
faire du pédalo tout seul sur son vélo
ça vous rassure ça marcel bénézet quand
vous entendez voilà mais ça veut dire
que les grands restaurants ceux qui ont
peut-être davantage de moi
1 seront favorisés par rapport aux
autres on sait qu'à paris souvent
l'étape quand même on est serré ça va
être compliqué de rentrer dans vos frais
puisque c'est ça qui vous inquiète
évidemment avec des distanciation d'un
mètre dans certains restaurants à paris
évidemment oui mais moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec monsieur legrand
qu'il a tout à fait raison
on a les établissements qui sont
ventilés on est annulée période estivale
où nos terrasses ont cru grand ouvertes
un peu insolite et bien sûr la météo ne
favorise pas l'ouverture nos terrasses
en grand mais nous avons quand même un
climat tempéré donc pourvoir nous nos
véranda en tournant bon je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de risque
dans nos établissements de contamination
du virus
surtout avec le port du masque pour nos
salariés attention on continue à
respecter les gestes barrière qui sont
très importants lavage des mains
fréquent nettoyage des toilettes
fréquemment des personnes des clients
avec un masque dans le sol attention il
faut quand même savoir que ce virus ces
virus virus circule encore dans dans la
en france donc il faut rester prudent
mais nous nous y aujourd'hui il faut
ouvrir nos restaurants vont plus vite
possible et vous avez le problème des
discothèques et des lieux festifs qui
sont encore laissé à l'abandon où ça va
être dramatique
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui vont
mourir au bord du chemin par rapport à
tous ces lieux festifs et certains
restaurateurs aussi bertrand legrand
justement sur ces lieux festifs c'est
vrai que ça c'est un voilà une épine on
va dire ça va être compliqué on a du mal
à imaginer que les français se
retrouvent en discothèque en train de
danser les uns avec les autres
ça va discuter cuisse ça va être
compliqué hein ce sera le dernier à
ouvrir afin d'ouvrir ans c'est évident
que tant qu'on a du virus les
discothèques vont être les plus durement
touchés de c'est assez évident ça c'est
indiscutable pour espérer un petit peu
je vais vous faire écouter ce qu'on
pense les français justement sur
l'accélération de ce déconfinement
écoutez je pense exactement de qui
serait bon de des confiné avec un
assouplissement des règles et des
distances sur l'intérieur en attendant
n'utiliser terrasse tant bien que mal en
fonction de la météo
mais pour l'intérieur il faudrait
assouplir les mesures de distanciation
je trouve que les jets les gens sains
peut ne pas générer
qui a entretenu et ça c'est pas c'est
pas très constructif
quand je pense que pour l'instant les
règles enfin l'app supplice mandela il
est déjà pas mal on peut continuer à
sortir déjà les terrasses ça fait du
bien on retrouve certaines habitudes
mais que plus plus vite on reviendra en
plus vite on reviendra à la normale
mieux ce sera mais en continuant de
faire attention c'est sur moi je sais
pas si ça a été fait comme ça c'est que
je pense ils ont quand même réfléchir à
ça vient après dans tous les cas ça va
reprendre petit à petit donc faut être
patient quand on entendait un
intervenant nous dire on entretient la
peur marcel bénézet vous partager un
petit peu cette analyse on en fait quand
même un peu trop aujourd'hui ça dépasse
voilà très prudents à une certaine
période il fallait vraiment attention
on revient de loin aujourd'hui on a
maîtrisé un petit peu ce ce mal mais je
reviens de loin aussi attention mais pas
de masque aujourd'hui on n'avait pas
nous on avait pas de gel ne concerne
trouver démuni de tout moyen de
prévention
aujourd'hui nous avons tout ce qu'il
faut nous avons mis en place un
protocole en solitaire qui est quand
même drastique qu'elle était très
compliquée à mettre en place
j'espère que tout le monde le respecte
mais nous sommes prêts à recevoir nos
clients pleinement dans les
établissements même sens distension d'un
mètre je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya paul
le risque est éloigné mais il faut quand
même garder ses gestes barrière c'est
tout le sérieux c'est la seule chose qui
peut nous préserver de tout risque de
retour du virus
peut-être la saison d'octobre ou
novembre
alors ça on parle son contrôle des
docteurs legrand qui disait
effectivement il faut de la prudence
mais bertrand legrand évidemment on a
tous envie de croire je vais pas encore
signé didier rahout m'enfin c'est vrai
qu'il disait voilà c'est un peu cette
épidémie elle va partir comme elle et
elle est arrivée
vous n'y croyez quand même pas cela
parce que vous dites oui si on fait pas
attention ça va revenir l'enfant voit
bien qu'il ya eu plein de de dérapages
des matchs sauvage des gens qui font pas
attention dans les parcs qui sont pas
masqué est pour le moment où tout du
bois on va dire
et bien le virus ne semble pas revenir
est ce que vous pouvez envisager cette
éventualité tout simplement qu'il
disparaisse avec la saison moi je reste
très terre à terre je regarde ce qui se
passe dans mon cabinet et la semaine
dernière j'aurais vraiment abondé dans
votre sens et puis cette semaine il a
fallu qu'une mère qui n'avait pas été
contaminé par ses deux enfants qui
étaient positifs de vienne contaminer et
donc du coup malheureusement je peux pas
vous dire que le virus ne circule pas
encore activement à l'intérieur des
foyers
ce qui me pose un problème or on voit
aussi qu'il ya quand même des clusters
qui se forment les uns après les autres
je pense qu'il faut rester extrêmement
simple on teste on teste et on re test
donc ça va vous faire plaisir c'est ce
qu'a dit raul mais mais je pense que
c'est parce que s'il ya aussi cette voie
là on parle beaucoup de la fiabilité des
tests en france aujourd'hui ailleurs
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui déteste que l'on
a nous permettent de faire du dépistage
met d'ailleurs on n'a jamais eu que des
tests de dépistage on n'a jamais eu rien
eu d'autre des tests qui ont été
utilisés à visée diagnostique ont été
une erreur je les dénoncer à multiples
reprises il faut les utiliser comme des
dépistages et donc aujourd'hui dépistage
veut dire tester n'importe quelle
personne qu'il accepte avec ou sans
symptômes
et c'est comme ça qu'on va isoler
certains positif est qu'on va faire
baisser la pression viral sur l'ensemble
de la population
donc oui il faut tester tester tester
tester la queue chez hrt merci bertrand
le grand merci marcel bénézet d'avoir
été avec mon direct sur rt france pour
évoquer ce déconfinement avec une
nouvelle date butoir on en parle on en a
déjà parlé le 22 juin eon
on évoquait justement tout à l'heure les
tests une autre question est celle qui
tourne autour des masques qui n'en peut
lui qui enfle d'ailleurs qu'ils
deviennent vraie polémique aujourd'hui
on en trouve partout et même trop
notamment des masques fabriqués par
l'industrie textile sollicité pendant la
crise pour coudre elle a du mal
aujourd'hui à écouler son stock
l'assemblée nationale se penche ce soir
dans l'hémicycle sur la gestion des
masques avec cette question comment la
france est passée en quelques semaines
d'une pénurie à des stocks entiers qui
ne trouve pas preneur
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
sylvie chaillou présidente de textile du
maine bonsoir sylvie chaillot merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
d'industrie textile sous l'impulsion du
gouvernement s'est mobilisé c'est votre
cas n'est ce pas au textile du maine
vous êtes dans quelle situation
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui nous avons interrompu
notre fabrication de masques nous étions
42 entreprise à s'être associés pour
produire massivement des masques on en a
produit près de 2 millions est
aujourd'hui la demande est pratiquement
à l'arrêt on doit vendre moins de quatre
mille masques par jour alors qu'on en a
vendu jusqu'à 100 milles par jour
alors depuis la mi mars environ 450
entreprises françaises se sont convertis
alors fabrication a parfois au prix
d'investissements supplémentaires
comment justement vous allez
rentabiliser ses investissements alors
une bon nous nous sommes sûrement une
corporation nous sommes des
confectionneurs et des maroquiniers donc
des machines à coudre des machines de
coupe nous avions nous disposions des
outils des outils nécessaires pour
fabriquer des masques donc nous on n'a
pas eu de soucis de d'investissement
mais je sais que il vient des collègues
notamment textiliens qui ont énormément
investi pour acheter du matériel de
fabrication et aujourd'hui ils sont en
grande difficulté puisque on ne peut
plus écouler on ne peut plus cool et nos
masques et on a les frais qui sont là
alors une réunion s'est tenue à bercy
aujourd'hui entre justement les
fabricants français de masse grand
public en tissu et la secrétaire
d'état le gouvernement qui vient de
lancer une mission de promotion du made
in france c'est à dire aussi pousser les
entreprises à utiliser des masques en
tissu lavable plutôt que c'est ces
masques chirurgicaux qui nous viennent
souvent de chine - écologique et moins
économique c'est un début de solution
pour vous de toute façon ça toujours été
discours de la ministre madame pas tenir
une hache et son souhait c'était
effectivement que l'on fabrique des
masques avec des normes françaises et et
que et que ce soit les masques
réutilisables ça faisait partie du
projet malheureusement au moment du des
confirmands et je pense qu'il ya une
grande panique de la part de beaucoup
d'acteurs qui ont importé massivement
des masques d'ailleurs et ce sont des
masques chirurgicaux pour moi masques
chirurgicaux sont des masques qui
doivent être portés par des soignants et
donc les masques qu'on nous a demandé de
fabriquer c'est vraiment des masques
destinés à protéger les gens qui
travaillent et les gens pour leur vie
quotidienne
aujourd'hui vous sortez de cette
expérience dans quel état d'esprit à une
forme d'amertume parce que c'est vrai
qu'on vous a sollicité on le disait
aujourd'hui voilà vous avez du mal à
écouler vostok c'est c'est sûr que c'est
une situation compliquée dans notre
groupement en fait on a six cent trente
mille euros d'investir afin de stocker
plus chaud aujourd'hui invendus donc
forcément on a pris un gros risque et on
sait pas comment se sortir de vraiment
de cette situation on va pas espérer
qu'il ya une seconde balle pour espérer
écouler nos produits donc on est
vraiment dans une impasse et il va bien
falloir que que les personnes qui nous
ont demandé de ceux de nous mettre cette
activité nous aide à nous en sortir
aujourd'hui clairement vous vous
retournez ainsi bishai ouvert le
gouvernement vous ont appelé à leur
responsabilité
donc il ya deux personnes un conte été
missionné deux personnes de la filière
qui ont été missionnés pour faire une
étude
donc ces deux personnes vont réfléchir
aux solutions éventuelles que l'on à
écouler nos masques vont les proposer
après au ministère et ce sera au
ministère d'arbitré mais de toute façon
on ne peut pas on a mis nos tripes sur
la table du jour au lendemain et du
fabricant de masques alors que c'était
pas du tout notre activité on a répondu
à un effort de congrès le président
c'est un effort de guerre donc
aujourd'hui on peut pas nous lâcher on a
répondu au pays aujourd'hui il faut
assurer il faut assumer
merci beaucoup sylvie chaillou président
de textile du maine d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france est
toujours en france le démontage de
l'échafaudage de la flèche de notre dame
de paris a débuté ce matin la flèche qui
était en restauration au moment de
l'incendié le 15 avril 2019
l'échafaudage a pas résisté à la chaleur
des flammes l'opération de démontage et
partie calciné durera tout l'été un
travail très délicat on en parle avec 4
ça pique nique sur place
c'est un chantier très technique qui a
démarré ce matin à 9h30
il va s'agir de déposer les quarante
mille pièces d'un échafaudage de 200
tonnes dont la moitié se situe à 40
mètres du sol
il s'avère que la flèche de viollet le
duc étaient en restauration avant
l'incendié bien évidemment la structure
de l'échafaudage a été très endommagé
donc il a fallu la consolidé durant de
nombreux mois à l'aide de poutrelles
métalliques et dresser un second
d'échafaudages autour et ce matin sur
les lieux
au début du chantier nous nous sommes
entretenus avec l'évêque auxiliaire de
paris monseigneur philippe de marseille
il nous parle de ce chantier très
technique
ah c'est un grand jour à cause de ce que
vous voyez juste derrière moi ou en fait
l'échafaudage qu'on va appeler le les
chèvres d'âge 2 va se servir de base
pour enlever l'échafaudage un qui était
celui qui était sûr autour de la flèche
de notre dame quand ça quand comme le
feu a pris et donc on va pouvoir
aujourd'hui à partir d'aujourd'hui mais
sur un travail qui va durer quand même
deux trois mois ou trois quatre mois
faire un diagnostic de l'état des
pierres de l'état des routes
sous cet échafaudage numéro un celui là
où a pris le feu et donc à partir de ce
travail de deux constats de constat on
va pouvoir déterminer un calendrier pour
la reconstruction de ce programme les
professionnels a donc des cordistes vont
découper partie par partie
les éléments calcinés qui vont être
déposées par des grues pour la sécurité
pour évidemment prévenir les chutes
trois filets ont été tendues et toutes
ces opérations vont être suivis par
guidage laser pour éviter la
vulnérabilité de la structure 2 manière
générale le chantier de notre dame a
connu de nombreuses péripéties puisqu'il
a été ralentie l'été dernier à cause de
la contamination au plomb
et puis à cause de l'épidémie la est
évidemment stopper il faut savoir que
cette nouvelle phase de travaux va
s'échelonner jusqu'à la fin de l'été
l'espace aérien rouvre peu à peu en
france alliant l'aéroport saint-exupéry
a repris timidement ses fonctions avec
son lot de nuisances sonores avec le
confinement et riverains ont à nouveau
pu apprécier le silence de la nuit très
calme un couvre feu aérien luis carballo
avec david khalifa un sons auxquels la
plupart des riverains de l'aéroport
lyonnais de saint-exupéry s'étaient
habitués mais dans cette zone
la fin du confinement marque le début
des ennuis nocturne pour des milliers de
résidents avec la reprise des vols de
nuit mais les reports reprend
progressivement ce lundi son activité en
temps normal saint-exupéry comptabilise
330 vols de jour pour 25 vols de nuit
passagers et marchandises confondues des
vols de nuit qui pose problème aux
riverains
et même si leurs soucis ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui le confinement a servi à
tirer des conclusions claires pour
l'association contre l'extension et les
nuisances sonores de l'aéroport
lyon-saint-exupéry
le confinement a permis de se rendre
compte du bien fait
d'avoir des nuits calmes et donc
nous avons profité de
cette perception pour pouvoir relancer
une idée qui nous est chère depuis fort
longtemps et qui est d'une part
la diminution si des vols de nuit voire
leur arrêt complet lors notre souhait
évidemment ce serait d'avoir une trêve
nocturne au minimum entre minuit et 5h
du matin de 20 ans permettre d'avoir une
quantité de sommeil qui ne soit pas
hachée par les différents vols pour
l'ensemble des riverains
et ce n'est pas la seule association qui
monte au créneau coriace le comité des
riverains de l'aéroport saint-exupéry
créée celle ci il ya presque un demi
siècle va encore plus loin
elle demande une table ronde avec les
pouvoirs publics nationaux et locaux
pour nous quelque part c'est une rupture
de l'égalité du droit du citoyen parce
que il n'y a pas de raison que dans un
aéroport on décide que les avirons de
telles catégories en termes de bruit ne
puisse pas volé parce que ça le
dérangeait gens et puis qu'ailleurs ça
n'existe pas le modèle économique
aujourd'hui il est plus basé sur le
profit immédiat
le problème c'est que on a complètement
occulté le modèle économique sociale
environnementale et durable et que on
peut pas indéfiniment continuer dans ce
sens là
pour l'instant aucune des deux
associations a reçu de suite favorable à
ces demandes
mais l'aéroport a lancé une étude
toujours en cours sur l'impact
économique d'un éventuel arrêt ou d'une
réduction des vols de nuit restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
partirons royaume uni qui impose 14
jours de mise à l'isolément tous les
voyageurs étrangers arrivant sur le sol
britannique sous peine d'une amende de
me lire puis direction les états unis où
l'émotion reste palpable après la mort
de john john floyd
l'ancien policier accusé de l'avoir tué
comparu aujourd'hui devant la justice du
minnesota
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifiques parlent comme anne de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui conteste naurouze
l'ordonnancé personnes non non c'est pas
vrai il ya des climats tous et non ce
n'est pas rien à part il ya des gens qui
ne sont pas des chercheurs qui parlent
que la presse met en avant parce que il
faut que du débat le ya plus de débat
aujourd'hui il ya plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va vers un
autre est vrai une catastrophe on va
vers une vraie catastrophe et on a
incapable d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimisme nous
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons de vue et les demis y
en a pas d 2000 ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france le
royaume-uni impose depuis minuit une
quarantaine de deux semaines à toute
personne arrivant de l'étranger et
mesures destinées à combattre l'épidémie
du nouveau coronavirus et qui sont bien
respectées pour le moment on fait savoir
le gouvernement britannique
elle est toutefois critiquée par les
compagnies aériennes qui menacent de
saisir la justice et par l'opposition le
maire notamment de londres écouter un
premier traitement le gouvernement a été
totalement incompétent dans la gestion
de la crise du coc vide 19 prenons cet
exemple ce lancement d'une quarantaine
imposée aux étrangers mais revenons en
arrière à présent en février dernier
lorsque d'autres pays se sont mises en
quarantaine sans que le gouvernement
britannique lui ne réagissent les gens
ramenait bien avec eux le virus à
l'homme ce gouvernement décide
maintenant de mettre en place cette
mesure mais il ya tellement
d'incohérences rien n'est clair en
réalité j'ai vu dans les médias des
passagers qui arrivaient dans les
aéroports et personne ne leur a posé de
questions personne ne les a mises en
quarantaine c'est une autre preuve de
l'incompétence de ce gouvernement et les
secteurs du tourisme autrement je ne
sont pas les salles inquiet de cette
mesure c'est aussi l'agacement pour ces
france est obligée de faire des allers
venues entre les deux pays qu ils ont
fait un nouvelle méthode
et il faut déclarer sur internet à la
vence où on va pourquoi comment et où
est ce qu'on va rester
quelle est la voie là et on est
normalement confinées 14 jours sauf si
on a une bonne raison ils ont fait une
liste de quarante bonnes raisons les
français sont aujourd'hui pour moi des
gens qui sont pas plus à risque de
pouvoir voyager donc pourquoi cette 14 n
c'est inexplicable en termes de gestion
de risques d'autant plus qu'il ya un
paradoxe qui est le fait qu'on ne porte
pas le mas systématiquement d'angleterre
je ne trouve pas que c'est une mauvaise
idée surtout qu'ils ont quand même
pouvoir les frontières que les gens
peuvent circuler je pense que si on est
responsable on se protège d'un côté josé
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis et ses terres au royaume uni avec
bharat en khâgne à expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir baratin pendant cagna
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on évoque avec vous cette
quarantaine imposée aux voyageurs au
royaume-uni c'était une mesure
nécessaire selon l'épidémiologiste que
vous êtes
c'est une nécessité pour tous les pays
en tout cas s'il souhaite endiguer
l'épidémie et il faudra attendre
longtemps avant de voir les résultats
tout d'abord il faut réduire le nombre
de cas maintenir un niveau bas et
stopper l'introduction de nouveaux cas
dans le pays c'est pourquoi c'est à ce
moment là que la quarantaine sera utile
en quoi précisément justement expliquez
nous le fonctionnement et en quoi est ce
nécessaire selon vous ça veut dire que
chaque pays à vouloir gérer ce virus
réussi peut-être endiguer l'épidémie
pour certains et ce en quarantaine ça
pourrait repartir à l'échelle notamment
européennes voire mondiales
yacine de sophos europe
kingdom hearts mieux européenne et le
royaume uni doivent être très clair sur
ce point il faut réduire et presque
supprimés
les cartes au sein des pays mais dans le
même temps qu il faut également éviter
l'introduction de nouveaux cas dans le
pays depuis l'étranger ou qu'il faut
réduire le nombre des cas au sein du
pays et en même temps en parallèle
empêcher l'arrivée de nouvelles
infections
donc il faut faire c'est deux choses en
même temps les mesures de quarantaine
prendront un certain temps parce que
nous avions déjà beaucoup de cas dans
notre propre pays et il faut traiter
déjà ce sujet aujourd'hui ces mesures de
quarantaine là on en parle entre le
royaume uni et la france mais est ce que
elles doivent est applicable avec tous
les pays du monde
selon vous quel serait l'intérêt est
appliqué cette quarantaine seuls
quelques contres ils posent les virus ne
respecte pas à l'effrontée à l'écriture
ou deux personnes le virus existent dans
le monde entier
donc il faut renforcer les frontières
les mesures de quarantaine devrait
rester à ce niveau de la quarantaine il
s'agit et de vous confier pendant 14
jours afin de s'assurer que vous n'êtes
plus contaminés et que vous n'êtes plus
contaminant donc il ne s'agit pas de
laisser entrer les gens dans le pays
tout simplement en les confinant pendant
14 jours
il faut avoir un suivi s'assurer que au
bout de 14 jours
la personne est en bonne santé afin
qu'elles puissent se déplacer sans
contaminer personnes est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas faire d distinguo entre les
pays où il ya des cas par exemple le
brésil aujourd'hui on sait que voilà ça
explose malheureusement en amérique
latine et des pays comme la nouvelle
zélande qui annonce aujourd'hui qu'elle
a totalement vaincu le virus avec juste
0 k voilà dans tout le pays est ce qu'on
doit pas faire quand même des
distanciation absolue
et oui nous tout à fait le problème
c'est que nous savons que la nouvelle
zélande se porte très bien avec elle
zéro mais vous le cas mais nous ne
savons pas ce qu'il en est pour d'autres
pays je suis d'accord avec vous si
quelqu'un vient zélande vient
directement de la zélande qui sèche d'un
vol direct entre la nouvelle-zélande et
le royaume-uni et qui n'a rencontré
personne sur ce vol alors il n'y aura
aucun risque d'infection mais s'il est
aussi difficile complexe de vérifier
cela que des contrôles et des mesures de
quarantaine sont tout de même nécessaire
cependant je suis également d'accord
avec vous des pays comme la nouvelle
zélande représente presque très bas et
des pays comme le brésil l'afrique ou
l'inde représente un très haut risque
vous comprenez enfin c'est peut-être
moins votre domaine vous êtes
épidémiologistes et est pas un analyste
des situations mais enfin vous comprenez
quand même le désarroi des compagnies
aériennes qui qui joue gros parce que ça
veut dire que si on impose une
quarantaine aux voyageurs ces derniers
ne vont plus vraiment vous allez voyager
c'est trop contraignant
je suis d'accord avec vous et mon
conseil pour l'année 2020
c'est de se rendre compte que c'est une
situation très difficile pour un
commentaire qu'il faut essayer de
réduire le nombre de nouveaux cas
partout sur la planète et donc je
propose d'annuler
mais les dominants de ressentir tous ses
problèmes toute cette douleur tous ces
migraines et d'attendre 2021 on l'espère
le virus aura disparu et je ne pense pas
que nous ayons beaucoup d'autres options
reset 2020 c'est une idée merci en tout
cas baratte bank kenya d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
aux etats unis les obsèques de djordje
floyd se tiendront demain à houston des
règles chauvin inculpé de meurtre a
comparu aujourd'hui pour la première
fois devant une juge lors d'une audience
de procédure organisée par vidéo
une caution d'un million de dollars pour
le policier accusé du meurtre de john
john floyd a été fixé là par ailleurs il
y aura une réforme profonde de la police
de minneapolis une décision du conseil
municipal
les explications de pernik aux deux
semaines après la mort de georges floyd
aux états unis la nouvelle est tombée le
conseil municipal de minneapolis a voté
le démantèlement de ces forces de
l'ordre nous ne sommes engagés à mettre
fin à la relation toxique de notre ville
avec les services de police de
minneapolis démanteler les services de
police tels que nous les connaissons une
décision inédite qui fait suite à celles
déjà prises vendredi dernier la ville
avait décidé de limiter l'usagé de la
force au sein de la police municipale en
bannissant notamment toutes les
techniques d'immobilisation au niveau du
cou mais une décision encore loin d'être
claires car les mesures pourrait mettre
du temps à se mettre en place
le maire de minneapolis jack up frais
lui s'oppose à l'abolition du
département de la police tout entier et
affirment préférer une profonde réforme
structurelle une déclaration qui lui a
valu d'être hué par les manifestants
[Applaudissements]
si vous me demandez si je suis pour une
réforme structurelle massive afin de
corriger ce système structurellement
raciste la réponse est oui si vous me
demandez si je ferai tout ce qui est
possible pour faire reculer les
inégalités inhérentes qui sont
littéralement partie prenante des
institutions la réponse est oui si vous
me demandez si je suis prêt à faire tout
mon possible pendant le reste de mon
mandat pour m'assurer que le syndicat
policier que les contrats des policiers
que le système d'arbitrage et que
certaines de ces politiques qui ont
affecté spécifiquement les personnes
noires et de couleurs et les meurtres
d'ailleurs sur plusieurs générations
je suis à 100% pouilles je ne suis pas
pour la pollution du département de la
police tout entier et je serai honnête à
ce sujet aussi minneapolis et depuis le
26 mai dernier le foyer d'un mouvement
de contestation qui a gagné tout le pays
et le monde entier si la situation
semble s'apaiser après plusieurs jours
d'émeutes plusieurs milliers de
personnes sera sans doute encore comme
ici à portland
les manifestants se sont notamment
rendus devant le palais de justice
agrippant en clôture alors que la police
leur demander de se disperser les forces
de l'ordre ont alors usé de gaz
lacrymogènes des tensions qui ont duré
jusqu'au petit matin
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
olivier python français installé aux
états unis avocat au barreau de
washington bonsoir olivier python merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
françois vous êtes donc on vient de le
dire basé à washington
première question est ce que le calme
est revenu sur place largement dire
qu'il y ait encore des manifestations
durant la journée mais elles sont
extrêmement pacifique
elles sont très calmes et en revanche
l'ensemble découvre son été a été levée
en particulier sur la côte est a par new
york et philadelphie qui avait encore un
couvre feu jusqu'à dimanche le
couvre-feu a été levé
preuve que la situation a quand même
tendance à se calmer ce qui est une très
bonne chose
reste maintenant le message qui est
véhiculée par les pacifistes par les
mails par une part les manifestants
pacifiques qui porte on l a vu bien
au-delà des frontières américaines et
qu'ils ont
autant d'impact je dirais même davantage
d'impact que les émeutes qui ont été
relativement mal perçue par une partie
de l'opinion publique américaine
donc c'est helmut ont tendance à avoir
totalement disparu
alors il ya un fait important évidemment
c'est la comparution de ce policier un
derek chauvin pour la première fois
aujourd'hui devant la justice ça va être
important ce qui va ressortir du procès
l'on imagine que voilà c'est une
décision forcément politique pour les
jugent absolument keirrison qui est le
procureur qui a donc diligenté une
enquête et qui a donc inculpé l'ensemble
de l'équipe des policiers autour de
chauvin effectivement par cette
inculpation a déjà fait vraiment baisser
la tension
deuxièmement maintenant on se trouve
face à un cas de figure qui est un tout
petit peu particulier qui existent
malheureusement depuis très longtemps
aux etats unis c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir démontrer que le policier
effectivement a commis un crime alors ça
paraît évident au vu des images ça
paraît évident au vu de l'opinion de
tout le monde mais il va falloir le
démontrer en droit et jusqu'à présent et
c'est l'un des problèmes que connaît la
société américaine c'est que les
policiers étaient d'une certaine manière
bénéficier si vous voulez d'une sorte de
je vais pas dire de passe droit mais en
tout cas de relative clémence hui égard
à leur à leurs capacités
donc on va voir la maintenance il avec
la situation telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui par la sphère georges floyd
les choses vont changer
et d'une certaine manière les policiers
américains à incriminer vont se
retrouver dans le droit commun c'est ce
que tout le monde souhaite parce que ce
serait ça la véritable avancée de cette
malheureuse à sion et vous nous parler
du côté intouchable entre guillemets de
ces policiers devant la justice
il ya souvent le poids des syndicats un
policier qui les aident beaucoup sur ce
point quel va être le rôle justement de
ces syndicats dans ce procès est ce
qu'il faut un petit peu profil bas une
fois n'est pas coutume lors les
policiers et les syndicats de policiers
jusqu'à présent
ne sont pas profil bas ils ont soutenu
la démarche des manifestants il ya eu
une vraie unanimité au sein des sociétés
américaines pour condamner ce crime et
pour estimer qu effectivement il y avait
un problème de violence intrinsèque de
la police je n'ai pas de racisme gdi de
violence la question du racisme est
beaucoup plus compliquée mais elle est
très belle
celle enquête qui déterminera
effectivement si l'acte a été
véritablement raciste et en os mais que
chauvin a subi 18 blâmer il va falloir
que les enquêtes déterminent si au cours
de ses actions qu'ils ont valu ses 18
blâme il s'est systématiquement mal
comporté avec des afro américains ou
s'il s'est comporté mal avec tout le
monde et dans ce cas là la chose serait
véritablement différente en tout cas en
ce qui concerne la violence
la société américaine de manière
écrasante souhaite effectivement un
changement de comportement de la police
avec une modification drastique à la
fois de son comportement dans la rue et
en même temps des peines qui peuvent
être lues être un film qui peuvent lui
être infligée dans le cas où elle se
retrouve effectivement confrontés à la
situation qu'on a décrit à quinze jours
avec eux le malheureux en audience sur
lui alors à minnesota à minneapolis 1 on
appris voilà le taureau par les cornes
la police va être carrément démanteler
ce qu'a annoncé les autorités ces sont
les prémices prémices d'un vrai
changement à votre avis vers quoi
va-t-on aller tout le monde est très
prudent sur cette histoire de
démantèlement d'abord joe biden a tout
de suite dit que c'était une décision
qui serait prise localement donc lui ne
s'est pas avancé en demandant le
démantèlement systématique de toutes les
polices entre guillemets à problèmes
donc c'est une décision qui sera une
décision locale puisque comme vous le
savez la police elle elle émarge en fait
auprès des municipalités des
collectivités locales sauf pour le cas
du fbi qui est un cadre un petit peu a
pas donc ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point si vous voulez dans cette
dans cette affaire
la véritable le véritable problème c'est
la proximité de l'élection
présidentielle
tout le monde marche sur des oeufs
chacun comprend bien qu'il faut réformer
les méthodes de la police dans la rue
mais personne n'a envie non plus de
laisser le pays totalement sans défense
où l'impératif de sécurité quand même
toujours présent et on l'a vu puisque
donald trump l'a utilisé à plein dans
son discours le one world heures c'est à
dire la loi et l'ordre
c'est dire que les démocrates essaye de
trouver un équilibre qui est difficile à
trouver entre le fait de répondre aux
aspirations des manifestants et en même
temps de ne pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain et de considérer que la police
sert quand même à quelque chose et
qu'elle n'est pas coupable
hand soit globalement en généralité si
vous voulez merci beaucoup olivier
python français installé aux états unis
avocat au barreau de washington d'avoir
apporté cette analyse sur la crise en ce
moment aux états unis et en france cette
fois une marche blake lively net à
nantes pour protester contre la
brutalité policière et le racisme est de
3000 manifestants se sont rassemblés
place de la république
la marche s'est ensuivie et vers le
mémorial pour l'abolition de l'esclavagé
accompagné de banderoles et de slogans
je ne peux pas respirer les derniers
mots de djordje floyd en france les
protestations porte aussi sur le cade
adama traoré décédé en garde à vue en
2016 écoutez ces quelques réactions on a
apparemment des très jeunes qui sont
regroupés pour se battre du coup pour
contre le racisme est aussi ensuite à
tout ce qui se passe aux etats-unis pour
montrer qu'en france si on se bat pour
les mêmes choses et que c'est pas juste
localisées aux états unis qu'on vit la
même chose ici on n'est pas d'accord
avec ce qui se passe dans le monde et
que son seul moyen pour nous qui est qui
et de manifester ont montré que du fait
que les violences qui sont produites
aujourd'hui elles sont pas justifiées et
en aucun cas être justifiables même
quoique aucune ariel a tant fait qu'ils
aient produit et le but de la police
censées protéger
par le peuple sa maman mais c'est pas du
tout le fait de quelqu'un on voit pas où
aller les chiffres montrent bien que ya
beaucoup plus de personnes de bavay rice
on sait qu'ils sont aujourd'hui on fait
juste au maroc à présent réponse ce
mercredi sur le confinement et sur son
éventuelle prolongation l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et le confinement ont été
reconduits déjà deux fois au faire face
à l'épidémie du coronavirus elmaleh 10 a
tué deux cent huit personnes au total
dans le pays et contaminé plus de huit
mille deux cent cinquante personnes
autre conséquence de la crise les
artisans traditionnels du royaume
craignent pour leur avenir un sujet un
sujet signé et l'âme et medjahed
cela fait maintenant près de trois mois
que les 238 l'artisan traditionnels du
royaume sont privés de revenus des
tisseurs des fabricants de sacs et des
sculpteurs de plâtre ou encore des
potiers qui désespèrent de voir les
touristes revenir je pense qu'après le
court aux navires usines ce métier va
disparaître
il n'y a pas de soutien aux aides
il disparaîtra je le dis sincèrement des
artisans traditionnels qui lance une
bouteille à la mer pour alerter sur le
naufrage de leur navire déjà bien abîmée
par la vague de l'épidémie
les juges la crise est passée mais notre
situation va s'aggraver
il n'y a pas de clients pour acheter nos
produits il n'y a pas d'acheteur puisque
les bazars sont fermés la crise n'est
pas terminée et pour nous elle durera
encore un an
il faut que l'état vienne en aide à ces
femmes dans la coopérative de la femme
créatrice à salé au nord de rabat une
trentaine de femmes testées tapis
d'ordinaire les tisseuses travaillent
huit heures par jour pour moins de 100
euros par mois
un maigre revenu dont elles sont
quasiment privé depuis que les tapis ne
se vante plus certaines travailleuses
ont pu obtenir des aides directes
débloqués par l'état sur un fond spécial
qu'ovide 19
d'autres n'ont rien eu d'une part
viennent
plus à payer leur loyer d'après la
coopérative alors les artisans
réfléchissent à des solutions en
attendant la fin du confinement le
retour des touristes et de la clientèle
locale
il faut que nous passions à la
commercialisation en ligne
on est obligés aujourd'hui de vendre à
distance puisque le client ne peut pas
se déplacer jusqu ici pour voir et
acheter
donc il faut qu'ils soient servis chez
lui céramiques bijoux vannerie et
meubles en fer forgé s'entassent dans
les échoppes déserte
en attendant que la vie reprenne son
cours normal il faut dire que
l'artisanat traditionnel contribue pour
7 % au pib et du royaume chérifien
avec un chiffre d'affaires à l'export de
plus de 90 millions d'euros l'an dernier
un secteur qui emploie deux millions de
marocains soit 20% de la population
active
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans moins
de dix minutes pour un point complet sur
l'actualité de ce lundi excellente fin
de soirée on se retrouve quand même dans
neuf minutes
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait pas devant le projet politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
compte et très très grands défis face
auxquels nous sommes aimés en arctique